[Musique]
bon le choc bonsoir les enfants on n'est
que tu es pressé et nounours mais petit
jamie mon feuilles sur les patrons y en
a de la chance aux sahraouis
[Musique]
et bien c'est tout ce désordre ma
surprise
[Musique]
des chaussettes une chemise
une salopette
mais oui ça y est ça ça cornichons
mon petit cornichons quelle surprise
mais comment es tu venu ici et là c'est
parano admis avec ta dah oui avec dead
il vanne de la laine au marché
c'est un passage ça alors vous en avez
de la chance mais bien cornichons nous
allons aider à faire ton lit oh non je
veux boli
il a apporté tout son matériel de
camping tout mon matériel cher cornish
ont dû dormir après notre champ
voilà là
[Musique]
l'une ayasse c'est ce qu'il donne
mêlerait de meilleure
amie shine
on sera partis
[Musique]
l'ont alors qu'est ce que j'entends
il n'est pas question de jouer quand je
serais parti
on a bien trop fan
compris nicolas
[Musique]
mais toi aussi cornichons tu as compris
alors
oui tu le passé
[Musique]
oui car moi dans la salle de bain tu
dors dans la salle de bains nounours
c'est pour avoir de l'eau fraîche quand
j'ai soif
bonhomie
corniche au salut
salut
le petit salé n'annonce
pas mais n'est qu'à la salle est pas
prêt de mal pour m
[Musique]
oh
pour une surprise c'est une surprise
cornichons est arrivé pas trop
pimprenelle et nicolas doivent être
contents oh oui revue robbie est bien en
route bonne nuit les enfants embrasse
bien fort vos parents une flaque d'eau
pour eux
salut
[Musique]